come on come on ed give me something
good [ __ ] you today I'm going to catch
so many goddamn pokemons and you're
coming along baby you're coming along
I'm gonna go my morning run but I'm
gonna bake your flat phone with me just
to catch pokemon while I run yes that is
as stupid as it sound but I wanted to
give it a try let's go
oh yeah it's a beautiful day to catch
some pokemons I don't know how this will
work out with me running at the same
time I realize how stupid it is but I
kind of love it
alright let's do this well this guy is
really strong come on come on you piece
of [ __ ] plane yeah [ __ ] you plane all
right we ran past the pier and we're
gonna keep going
is this a [ __ ] lot into Pokemon here
open your eyes
they're everywhere come on you [ __ ]
crime there you go
I realize how much slower I run but it's
[ __ ] worth day
people look at you like you're crazy and
I probably am but this is I think this
is the fastest way to cash in Pokemon
okay there's a gym right there Shelton's
boss I'm level 12 the gym is right there
do you mind if I come in come on you got
the gym by yourself [ __ ] man
he's got the gym locked up people have
changed people are barricading the gyms
now Oh Pokemon whoa are you kidding me
they're just keep appearing man all
right eat some raspberry [ __ ] you this
is painful
men suck a [ __ ] dick Oh for [ __ ]
sake
No No
goddamnit I guess you can't catch them
all I'm actually genuinely pissed about
that
don't talk from you right now someone
has a journalist the [ __ ] man how can
you have a jurado's already what the
[ __ ] man get a life your nerd go inside
14 kilometers in I'm back where we
started
but I'm gonna keep going baby cuz I got
so many Pokemon and I'm gonna catch them
all [ __ ] I don't know where the [ __ ] I
am I think it's time to go back oh yeah
I feel pretty good there's sweat and
smudge all over the [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of my back squirrel oh those sexy
legs oh sorry
I'm recording I've caught so many
Pokemon so many passion
I ran 22 kilometres just to catch
pokemon I got a tan for the first time
then Pokemon is changing people okay so
these are all the pokemons I found this
is ridiculous oh my god it keeps going
guys what are you doing on my dinner
table Drowsy this is the cutest Pokemon
of them oh oh okay
I can't catch her though you're useless
you're useless
alright now it's time to upgrade and
evolve my pill canals first of all this
drowsy is gonna be powerful as [ __ ] go
drowsy I imagine he good
I imagine he gets swapped out by someone
else hypno
would you look at that 800
I caught a slope up for you by the way
yeah
can we just genocide the drowsies
already and I think that's about it
let's have a look at our team now we got
a really strong hypnopaedia hypno thank
you I'm trying to talk Pokemon here
Jesus that was a very successful hunt
but we're just beginning might say we're
going to London today right what are we
gonna do in London pokemon hunting
that's what we're gonna do
let's go actually I gotta charge my
batteries oh my god there's a giant ass
crab right there Edgar do you see it
there's a giant ass crab right there
well how do we find it
let's uh grab this phone if you find any
pokemons dammit I clicked one button
we're chasing a giant crab you're moving
yeah we're moving we're gonna drive to
Peter's gym PJ's so proud of his
Blastoise dude I'm so proud of my
blaster look at my blaster sphere legs
well I'm gonna blast your Blastoise to
space
I can I'm doing it six percent battery
bro for [ __ ] sake the driver okay
alright alright are we here
this is illegal but it's okay cuz it's
Pokemon battle begins go hip now piece
of [ __ ] Blastoise used ice beam more
like lamby
hey nice filming I got that you win and
it's open for business for pewt there
you go there you go PJ you got rekt
that's my gym now what's that stupid and
unnecessary and could anyone gotten hurt
absolutely
I'm getting really addicted to the game
it's so much fun it reminds me of when I
was playing MMOs a bit when I was a kid
and I'm glad like friends like PJ's
playing it as well cuz so I can wreck
them I'm working on the office I'm gonna
do a real like setup tour when it's done
getting all the cables sorted and moved
it into like this server Locker but it's
only so I can have like all my consoles
and all that cuz being a youtuber you
were gonna have to deal with hey hey the
[ __ ] are you doing pooping on my carpet
what's wrong with you being a youtuber
you have to deal with a lot of cables
it's bull [ __ ] is dog [ __ ] oh yeah it
looks pretty [ __ ] good though got a
reply from PJ you bastard your finish
you hear me
ah sweet victory alright that looks
pretty [ __ ] good look at that [ __ ]
yeah I love my setup that's how you get
to sleep for now me MRSA going to London
now god I really hate going to London I
can't believe we're going
thank the Lord 40 gotta go so fast
Thank You birdies hill-station
appreciate it do you want to try it
let's just see your skills
so you gotta flick it harder ooh
bullseye I'll come on now this is
paintball gear to me don't mind me just
running to London oh my god hey my tag
on your Pokemon it's practically so Sam
strip and posted this yesterday
everyone in LA is playing on Santa
Monica Pier and a Wartortle appeared and
this happens that's crazy
that's insane
this game is changing the world man I'm
curious to see what pokemons we can find
in London they sold it like there would
be like different ones in different
cities which i think would be really
cool I hope they will update it like
that
don't let me down intend oh okay we're
here might have to do a video thing I'm
just coming along as a good boyfriend
trust me I do not want to be but
pokemons he's making it okay finally a
real Pokemon we are real sound I just
okay yeah I'm actually miss exciting of
the moment yeah so many people see that
you're playing and they approach you and
they want to talk about the game I think
that's really cool I never talked to so
many strangers just cuz I'm playing a
game you know in person at least I think
it's really cool it's really interesting
might say you're done with your thing
we're gonna go back to Brighton right
away yeah so tired actually that run
really killed me this morning I really
like the game but I think it could be so
much more
imagine if you could challenge people
when you see them on the street I think
I think the game could be so much more
right now it's kind of buggy I still
really enjoy not gonna have this part
here let me know if you want to do part
3 I'm really enjoying this game hope you
bros are enjoying the episodes and as
always take
Oh
you